[Applause]
[Music]
yeah alright what's going on going on
everyone sorry about that I'm saying
part this is Alex Cheung founder of
hippie Lindsay rattle off a few stats
but there's a few things interesting
basically how many of you have used
giffy right so they have 500 million
people a day going to the website so the
likelihood that you've been there is
quite high so Gibby's pretty interesting
not only because they have 500 million
people a day coming to the website but
they've done this in a crazy short
amount of time so the site was launched
in February of 2013 right yep you have
over a hundred employees or about 100
employees base here but you've built
this very huge website very huge brand
very very quickly raise 150 million
dollars so you guys have done a lot in a
short amount of time so today we're
gonna talk a little bit about that story
but I'm a pretty I said this at my last
Q&A I'm a very casual person and I want
to make this about you all so I'm gonna
have this iPad up the whole time and go
to what's called a slide Oh slide Oh
calm type-in hustle carnies and ask
questions as we go and I'll be able to
pull them up but first of all welcome
hey thanks thanks for being here so tell
us a little bit about give some contacts
I already gave a little bit of contacts
but give a give contacts as to what
context as to what giffy is how big it
is just so people have a little bit of a
background of the company yeah so if he
is a search engine so we are essentially
a search engine but the difference is we
are the only search engine and messaging
so you know messaging is blowing up
right now if you look at your screen use
time it's probably all iMessage or
messaging apps there has never really
been a company or it or a product that
has been able to create search inside of
a messaging app and that's exactly what
we've done we're in every messaging app
in the world we're in snap Instagram
whatsapp we
not reach out yet sorry oh very soon
someday except for the whole Chinese
like situation going on right now we're
in all the messaging apps we have the
number one behavior we've gave people a
search and messaging right now over we
know that at least 500 million people
use search every day in giphy and we
serve about more than 7 billion pieces
of content a day so we're at scale now
and so we you know we we pretty much can
hit everyone on the internet our reaches
if you think about snap and Facebook and
whatsapp they all have user reach and
it's it's it's kind of peaked out
because they've kind of maximized how
big their products are going the the big
difference that we've done is were a
superset of all companies because we are
embedded in every one of those apps so
our reach is exponentially growing all
the time so we can reach pretty much
everyone on the internet at any given
moment got it and so Alex and I have
been chatting over the past couple weeks
to prepare for this and I thought that
his story was most it was one of the
more interesting stories in of everyone
I've talked to because he has a very
unique philosophy and perspective on
life you know someone like me I think I
just wanted to I like building
businesses they're exciting for me I
tend to kind of stick for one thing for
a while
whereas your career you've jumped around
you could you consider yourself you said
you feel like a musician almost like a
rock star and you're able to jump around
I didn't say that
what did you say so no so fire a rock
star with Sonu well what did you say no
I said it's like a bad okay I got really
bad like indie rock band you know like
playing over in Bushwick
maybe Greenpoint every once in a while
if we were cool enough so you said
you're like a band sorry yeah because
you're you jump around from project to
project and that's not something that
people typically say when they're
raising money or talking to people and
so your outlook is is significantly
different from most everyone I've talked
to or at least you admit it and they
don't so to talk about like how this
outlook came to be can you explain a
little bit in like 30 or 60 seconds to
your background and kind of how you got
to to where you are now
I originally an engineer so I'm a
hardware engineer but so I worked in
hardware I worked at Intel I worked at a
bunch of different places and then I
went to school here at Parsons and went
back to design so I was a graphic
designer and the fashion scene for a
little bit but I found out you can't
really make money at the graphic
designer or actually like you can't make
money at anything in New York and so
then you have to go back into doing tech
which is like the only place where you
can actually make a decent living
so with that you know if you're going on
that you're the year-long kind of
strategy it's really I mean I think
everyone who's young knows I'm a little
older than all of you I just maybe look
a little younger but I'm not Millennials
right now they do about a year maybe
it's less actually like a lot less and
then they'll jump from jump you know
like it's called you know they call it
the gig economy but it's really about
trying to maximize as much as you can do
in a short amount of time and then
moving on which is exactly if you think
about like bands what they do is you do
an album you go on tour and they figure
if no one wants to go on tour then you
go on to do another album you and that
may suck and then you keep doing it
until you like get in a Volvo commercial
and then you're making a ton of money
and then you just end up doing that one
song forever until you get really old
and then go on tour so what we do is the
way that I try to figure I've been doing
startup since it's been 25 years since
the early or late 90s and this is about
my 12 startup I've been a part of a
bunch of different startups that people
have done I found it a bunch of startups
and what you really want to do is you
want to optimize for that first year you
know I've spent a lot of time in
companies trying being super stubborn
and trying to get something to happen
and you want to be a little bit stubborn
but you also want to know when it's not
the right time in place when your song
is like not gonna be number one on the
Billboard you know top 40s and so you
usually try to put a year in which is
kind of like how school works right it's
your major you put a year in and then
you kind of see where you are at the end
of the year and if you can keep going
then you do a year at a time so it's not
when people young people say hey we're
going to do this for the rest of our
lives you're like okay if your company's
still around maybe and then if you stand
then when you grow up and you like have
things that you want to do and you have
to lay
be a part of the world maybe so well the
way that I like to think about it is you
you plan for four or five years you plan
for forever but you go in one-year
chunks and you do as much as you can in
a year and then you if it doesn't work
you fold that and then you move on which
is pretty much what I've been doing with
my career for most of my life so I'll
play I told you this earlier I was like
oh I'll play devil's advocate on that
because you're you said that you plan
you you said I'm not gonna plan it too
far in advance because I don't know if
my company will even be around in a year
but yeah where you guys are now you've
raised 150 million dollars you're at
scale the likelihood that you're gonna
be around for a long time is quite high
and you never know you're right but I
would bet and a hundred and fifty one
things 150 million things have bet that
you're going to be around for a while
when you're talking talking to investors
are trying to raise money or trying to
recruit employees do you tell them that
you're only looking ahead one year at a
time or you're only planning one year at
a time like that because if I were
wanting to invest I would be nervous
about that no I think I would take the
other way investors want to know that
you have a one-year plan they don't want
you to be like investors you got to
remember VCS have a seven-year return
window you need to return their money
and they need to make 10x on their money
because they're capitalists right so
like I mean Jeff Bezos just said like
last week that he was hoping you know he
was waiting he was just holding on to
until the eventual day when Amazon fails
all companies will fail at some point
someone's just going to come out and be
better so what the VCS what they really
want to do is if you follow Paul
Graham's
maybe it's my mind if you follow like YC
Paul Graham's advise startups are all
about growth and so if you're not
growing then you're not a start-up and
you're not doing something successful
and you probably have a year to make
so the way that I go into VC meetings is
hey in a year we're going to be here and
I usually put a 10 X number on whatever
our KPI is and I'm like this is what I'm
committing to and if we can raise the
money we will get there and if you can
get there then you're successful the
worst thing a VC wants to see is hey in
one year in five years we're gonna do
this thing and then there's no plan for
the first year and it's going to take us
maybe four years to figure it out and
then we'll figure it out on the fifth
year they want to see growth right away
and so if you plan your Li growth 10 X
10 X 10 X 10 X that's exactly what they
want to see and if you can't pull that
off maybe you get a little bit more time
but if you can't pull that off for two
years then you should probably sell the
company or do some find something else
because you just aren't there at the
right time in place so I'd say VCS
actually prefer you to optimize for the
year so especially for the next round of
funding but have a outlook for the
future so you plan for the future but
you really really operate in you're a
year at a time so well then what would
happen if your company didn't tenha I
mean a lot of people when they're first
getting started like I get I get asked
this question all the time when do I
know when to quit or how do I know when
to quit
and is that your metric is 10x growth I
mean like if you didn't hit that would
you what would you do yeah I think
because startups are all about growth
it's only there's only two things that
you're optimizing for you're optimizing
for traffic or people right like you're
looking for user growth or you're
looking for revenue growth and there's
two types of businesses if you want to
make an e-commerce company that's just a
lifestyle business that's making money
don't take any funding take the bare
minimum you can and then you're just
kind of chilling out and you're making
money and that's totally fine that's
like you know having a pizza parlor or
having any kind of like operating
business that's a totally cool thing to
do and there's funds for that but if
you're talking about high growth hyper
growth startups unless you're making 10x
gains every year your company probably
isn't going to be on the hockey step
curve if you follow that you know like
everyone talks about the hockey
though that's an exponential growth
that's gonna be 10x growth every year so
if you can't do that and when you're
starting out then there's something
fundamentally wrong about your product
market fit or you're not operating
correctly you give it a little bit of
time and then you pivot or you either
there's a couple options either then
just start making revenue and then just
build a business like a small growth
business or you keep optimizing for
trying to get that curve up if you can't
get the curve up at some point there's
something wrong right and that's when
you have to ask yourself this is
something that you want to keep doing or
do you find something else when you were
starting out was your goal I mean I'm
sure it's many people's gold to find
that 10x growth company but did you
start it thinking I think this can grow
10x or did you feel like you just
started something fun and fell into it
so it's that's I look at it differently
it's not like you have an idea and you
think it can grow 10x like obviously
anything can grow 10x possibly but it's
more you just put the number on the
board and you say what are all the ways
you're gonna get there because if
something was so obvious that it's gonna
grow 10x naturally like someone would
have already done it you know like
someone's gonna pull it off it's like
gonna be it's it's uh it's too easy of a
problem to solve so what you really want
to do is take the thing that no one
thinks it's ever gonna be big like a
gift search engine and then put 10x on
the board and then figure out every
possible way that you can get to that
10x and then that is when the creativity
opens up and you're like oh like in our
case it was like we did we actually did
10x every year for the first four years
and it was like 10 you knows like three
million people than it was 300 thousand
three million 30 million three hundred
million so we've been doing that every
year and we got to a point when we were
like there's no way that this is gonna
do this without we're not gonna be able
to hit 300 million until we get onto
Facebook but Zuckerberg had just said
that he would never put gifts on his
platform like two months before and so
everyone's like you're dead and we're
like no we need to get this gifts onto
Facebook and so we hacked this whole
solution into Facebook through
like a flash player where you could
actually play gifts on to Facebook and
we did it and then you see the 10x grow
and then next year we were on stage at
f8 with Mark Zuckerberg and he was
sending gifts on the gift II platform
and so it really is put the put the goal
and then go towards the goal if that
answered that question yeah it does when
you when you did create that huge goal
but something I've I don't know if you
guys experienced this but when I'm
working with team my team as CEO or
founder I'm like I'll create these huge
goals and there's immediate pushback of
like oh that this can't be done what did
you do to motivate your team oh yeah if
you put these things there's two types
of people they see that as we can't do
that and there are other people that are
oh that's a crazy goal I wonder how we
get there and the people that we work
with are the ones that are like I if you
give me 1% chance off and it's possible
we will figure out a way I like the low
odds because the high odd things like
those are boring want one they're boring
and everyone's doing them I like if
you're in Bitcoin right now lurking or
crypto it's like a billion companies are
doing obviously well now everyone's
losing money but if it's like a gift
search engine and no one really knows
what you're doing and you put these
goals it's a challenge so I think the
startup people the people who are the
boldest and the craziest are the ones
that are going to see the 1% chance and
go for it and then figure out the plan
to get there and then have the team that
is going to embrace that small chance of
winning because being the underdog and
doing something crazy like we are doing
a large percentage of Google search
traffic like we are like a multiple
chunk of Google search traffic no one
thought we could compete with Google
they have 30,000 employees we have a
hundred but yet we're competing every
day and beating them and so I love that
and you want a team that has that kind
of challenge if you have a team that's
like we can't do this you have the wrong
team and your startup is gonna fail
everyone just work at Google or Facebook
because that's where people go when they
give up
so just a reminder if you do have a
question just message me here and I'll
pull it up guys like that talk to me a
leg up they all work at Facebook talk to
me a little bit about the very first six
months of the company what was where did
the idea come from and what was it what
were the first maybe three to six months
of trying to get users like so uh in the
very beginning it was a project that a
friend and I were talking about I had
been doing I had done like six other
projects and launched them and we added
like a anonymous chat thing we had like
a a non-profit like square reader thing
we were working on we crypted some
crypto stuff so this was just one fun
project out of it's like if you're
putting out an album this was just one
of like the b-sides that we put out and
it was uh ended up taking off and in
maybe 15 minutes of it starting to get
traffic we got offers from everywhere
for funding wait wait wait wait
what how did you even get how did they
get that much traffic early on someone
you know I actually just never meant it
to go public I sent it to four friends
just as like a fun thing for us to
define just fine and we're like oh this
will be our secret weapon we can now
find gifts on the Internet when no one
else can and then someone like sent it
to a friend and they sent it to a friend
and then it got on the cover of Gizmodo
and then it got cover um of everywhere
and then people were yelling at me
because they were telling me it's soft
and I was like I wrote this and like
about that long the search engine was
like three lines of code and so then in
the neck the first month was just me
working on it full-time
just trying to get it not to crash we
got offers of funding and then I was
like okay we'll take a little bit I
brought out all my unemployed friends to
come work on it
they were happy because they had jobs we
ended up like we had work at home
Wednesday's which is like not a good
idea and so the first few months it was
just us hanging out just trying to
figure out what is this thing and we
would you know we'd go to the standard
and Mike have wasters and like
this back when Rosa was still a thing
and we would hang out and then six
months into it we were like okay if
we're going to devote the next year of
our lives to this let's like commit to
it and then let's think about the plan
of what we're trying to do and that's
when we put the 10x goal on the board
and then we got serious and we started
coming up with a strategy and you can
exactly see if you look at our Google
Analytics our traffic was like you know
big peak and then they call it the
trough of despair where in all your
traffic goes away and it Peaks out until
we for like three or four months until
we got serious and then the traffic goes
like that and it's been going that way
since those first six months when we
stopped eating oysters what were you
doing to get that traffic up everything
I mean like you matters what kind of for
us in the very beginning it was SEO like
we wanted to be synonymous with gif it
was getting integrated into platforms it
was pretty much every trick you could
possibly think of to get traffic in the
very beginning it's very easy to double
your traffic cuz you're only talking
about hundreds of thousands of people
when you start getting into the tens of
millions you have to change your
strategy to something a little more
drastic and wanted to start going into
the hundreds of millions of people
that's when you have to start picking
backing off of the large networks so
your strategy always change with every
other goal and so uh you know our what
we were good at was constantly changing
the strategy for the goal that we put on
the board so you have to be super
adaptive because the internet changes
every day huh when you are working with
your team how often were you changing
strategy every day so and how many
employees did you have when you're
changing every day because I got what I
love doing is I love going to companies
that I like or startups that are growing
quickly and I like looking at the glass
door
we're job reviews on how to handle
creepy what I like looking at what's
what employees say it's like to work
there because I want to learn what good
CEOs are doing or how what bad CEOs are
doing so I don't do that and one thing
that most a lot of people complain of is
strategy is constantly changing so when
you were doing that how many people were
you and how are you doing
with that you know we in the very
beginning there were five of us for the
first almost year and then we went we
doubled to like ten and then twenty and
now there's a hundred and we used to
reorg every month because when you have
five people you can't just do one job
you have to do all the jobs and so we
would reconfigure for every strategy and
so we kept reorg again we made it every
quarter and now then we made it every
six months and now we all now there's
enough people that we do it about once a
year and if you are that type it's a
start-up you know we we are competing
literally competing with Google and
Facebook every day and we we don't have
the resources to compete with them so
there's no way we're gonna beat them on
a head-to-head basis so we have to be a
lot more clever and we have to change
and we have to adapt because uh you know
the benefit we have is work far more
creative or so we think but we are much
more nimble and we can change faster we
can change our product in a day and they
take that it takes some months or years
to change their product so I would say
you need a in a startup set scene if you
don't have employees that are ok with
that you're going to fail like it just
is the nature of the game like there's
you know people will come in and say hey
we need a four year plan if you have a
four year plan you've already failed
because you that means you haven't it
you're not adapting to the changes of
market so we have to change all the time
it's a fundamental nature of the company
and so you know what we do is I think
part of why what why people stick around
to is you know in our company values we
have all these crazy values one is the
heart emoji we optimized for the company
first so like we have this thing where
it's a one of our sayings it's like
product over people or people over
product that's sorry that was from that
was from Google where we optimized for
the people in the company and when you
optimize for the the environment of the
people then all the products naturally
end up showing up but when you optimize
for the product you get a bunch of
people that just care about their their
careers and the product and not about
the community of people that are
actually working on it so
if you ever watched Friday Night Lights
it's like we are that Odessa like not
that awesome well staffed or but kind of
like attractive team and we just end up
doing just better than everybody else
because we're just craftier because we
have to be and we like each other that's
one big thing how so you have this very
you may push back on this but you have
this very family-oriented culture it
seems like right yeah the difference
between a family and a team is you can't
fire your family so whereas on a team
you can replace someone so how are you
balancing this this culture with the
reality that you have to make money you
have to you have people you have outside
investors to please so there are two
types of bands both of them are on giffy
like let's say there's like the Beatles
who were a band and they stuck together
as the as the music changed they went
from like the 50s all the way to like
6070 they've got and they made crazy
different albums if they all stuck
together even though they had tensions
they were a family so it was really
about the people first and the music
second and then you have bands like war
like who knows who's in court they just
get random people coming in and for that
that's all about the music and not about
the people and that totally works but
that's why they can never change they
could never not wear costumes and like
do this whole thing because that's like
the one thing they do right so if you're
gonna be adaptive you have to really
focus on the people of the company
because you need to be able to change
configuration pivot do all these things
so we spend a lot of time on building
the community of the of the company most
of the first early employees were
friends of mine you know people who know
you know they're not going to abandon
you for a job at Facebook or Google like
we're all in it together like we always
say like we either succeed together we
or we fail together and if people aren't
you know useful in when we grow we try
to find other roles for the
like we it's like people are going to
we're gonna optimize for the people and
what their best good at so any we've had
multiple people large percentage of
people move roles within the company
over the last five years and we'll move
people and we'll try to get them to the
the best point they are one thing that
we have is we have another value that we
call post goofy because I think a lot of
companies think that this is going to be
your like last job ever and that's not
true like everyone here has unless
you're like just right out of college I
have multiple jobs right that company
that you were at last year is not or
maybe four years ago if you're you five
years ago was not the was not the
company that you you're gonna be in in
four or five years so are promised
everyone is we are going to give you the
skills and the training to be better and
make a lot more when you leave the
company than when you started
so we we put that commitment on and
people stay and we've had very little
turnover over the years because and then
when people are ready to leave I'm
always surprised that people are long
are sticking around longer than a year
but when people stay for four or five
years and if they want to leave her like
great you know now go be fancy someplace
else but say nice things about us and
maybe not a Facebook or Google cuz
that's giving up talked about the
business model we actually didn't
mention it but basically you have five
hundred million people some of your what
coming in coming to give you a day you
you've raised all this money you said
that you're starting to make revenue
this year a lot of speakers we have who
speak at these events our bootstraps so
they're making money from day one you're
a little bit you're not in that category
so talk about how you're playing on on
building the business and the very
beginning you know it was you you you
have a couple different like again you
either optimize for growth or you
optimize for revenue if you try to do
both you're most likely gonna fail it
both and you're not gonna get hyper
growth like hyper growth like if you
look at it making money is actually the
easiest problem easier problem than
having growth a lot of people can make
money or have really good retention but
it's really hard to get hundreds of
millions of people to your platform
so we optimized for growth for the first
five years and that's where we got to
and now that we have scale like we have
more inventory in our platform than we
know what to do now it's about turning
on to the the second phase of revenue
growth and that's what we're doing right
now so we started in January and our
business models very very simple
the two most monetizable platforms on
the internet are Google and Facebook one
is us one is an ad network an ad
platform based off of search and one is
an ad network based off of feeds and so
our business model is very simple we are
search and messaging so and we also have
feats in messaging so these are trending
feeds so we just follow the Google and
Facebook model and that's all we're
doing we are the largest ad network and
messaging right now no one's been able
to figure out how to monetize messaging
because no one's been able to create an
ad network in messaging since we're in
every messaging app in the world and we
have the search behavior we can now
build and what this is what we have
built the world's largest ad platform
for messaging so for you know the way to
think about it is every possible message
is a possible search and every possible
search is a piece of media and every
piece of media the potential ad so
there's seventy eight trillion messages
sent every year if you've monetized that
at Facebook CPM that's that's almost a
true that's like 780 trillion or a
billion dollars in in revenue potential
right there just in messaging and that's
oh that's more than global advertising
right now so messaging has the potential
to be as big as the entire advertising
ecosystem and that's all we're doing we
just want one percent of that maybe to
no big deal I mentioned this earlier
with active when I was adaptive but
something that I hear often is people
say before they're starting something
they get nervous about all the legal
implications typically what I say to
them is like you know you first need to
create something a product that users
actually want people actually want and
then like if I were you I would worry
about
making sure that legally you're
perfectly sound because the likelihood
that you're going to get sued is a lot
lower than the likelihood that you're
going to create something that people
actually want so focus on that first you
guys are in a similar or aren't up in a
field where I would imagine you get a
lot of law like people threatening to
sue you for copyright reasons is that no
no no no no no no what oh you can talk
about most San Francisco startups I
won't name them they're friends of ours
they all ride off of fair use fair use
is cool and like there's a lot of legal
precedent on it but once you start to
try to monetize no one wants to
advertise on your platform when you're
using a bunch of weird like fair use
kind of stuff that maybe they're content
on the internet so I used to work at MTV
on music videos on Midtown and I did a
lot of the licensing on that side so day
one we we we decided to be a hundred
percent licensed content so we have a
bunch of UGC content which is about 10%
of our catalog but 90% of our catalog is
all licensed so this is every sports
league the NFL NBA all those all of the
the movie studios all the pretty much
anything that you see we have licensed
so we have actual rights to distribute
that and our users to use which is
something that no one else in the world
really has and that took us five years
to get that's why we're totally from a
copyright point of view we've we don't
have problems because we work with the
artists and the content providers
directly because they see this as a huge
win where here's someone that's not
ripping off their content that's working
with them directly and so this is why we
get that it's easy for us to get
advertisers because we've been so
straight on board with that I we have
about eight minutes left
alex has specifically said that he may
not answer every question but every
question is he's game for any question
to be asked so if you do have something
that you you you want to at get ass or
get answered feel free to put it up
there because we've talked about how
he's not afraid of
any question can you talk about some of
the let's states with this question
advice for building the tech MVP so your
first version has a non-technical
founder you built yours in-house right
yeah built myself yeah don't don't out
like it's very hard to outsource your
product because the life cycles are too
slow you outsource it and then you like
get feedback and then you outsource
again you get feedback if you're gonna
like if you have a small growth company
where you just need an app that doesn't
need iteration and you can make a little
bit of money that's - oh it's right
there - it's totally cool that's fine
but if you're actually gonna try to
compete on some hyper growth scale you
have to have a technical co-founder like
you have to be you need to build it
in-house there's no way that you're
gonna compete because you have to again
you have to be faster and more clever
than all the other people you're
competing with and if it's a good idea
which it probably is some YC company is
going to crush you
like day one so why even bother you know
like every day people come out of
business schools saying I have the
greatest idea it doesn't really matter
there's a lot of great ideas it doesn't
matter until you build it like you just
have to be able to build it yourself
when you were what you've worked on a
dozen or so companies in your career
were you ever partnered with someone who
wasn't technical yeah so I timed I would
I pick to be like who cares like a lot
of time it's like John and Lenin and
like Paul McCartney right even though
Paul wrote all the all the songs they
both still get credit like I I was the
CTO of half those companies you know
because I'm the technical person a lot
of times I have a business person cuz go
figure like engineers and designers we
don't really like talking to people too
much like we spend all of our time
locked in a basement working on code
like we are naturally not social people
and then will they come on stage and
have to talk to people but I'd rather
just be at home like working on stuff
maybe watching some TV not that this
isn't awesome thank you but so you you
want a partner it's usually a technical
person you want like a little bit of an
introvert and you want an extrovert
someone that goes out and does all the
business meetings because you know that
person is not building anything but the
person building something doesn't have
the time to go out and do all of that
stuff so 80% of startups
successful startups are done by two
people or more YC almost never invest in
a startup of one person but on the
corollary side 65% of stars failed
because of founder tension so like
you're not gonna get there unless you
have a co-founder but you're more likely
gonna fail because of your co-founder so
what do you do when you were working
with some of your business
co-founders what was one of what made
you interested in working with them
friends first like I I made the mistake
in the long in the early days of just
picking the smartest people that thought
were cool and eventually what happens is
you got a lot of money and then people
get greedy or like people don't have
different interests or you know you your
your your professional careers diverge
and there's nothing personal keeping you
there together and so now I only work
with friends because friends you know
and people say it could ruin your
friendship well you know if you're in it
with a company and you're in your really
truly friends you'll see it through like
you'll see it through to the end right
like I would rather work with me and
also like if you're gonna work with work
eight twelve sixteen hours a day you
wanna hang out with your friends right
like you don't really want to hang out
with random people that left Google do
you have a Facebook profile I do but I
deleted all my posts like years ago so I
had every profile but there's no content
cuz like why would you be on social
media right let's answer this top
question yeah and this is this is
interesting for me as well because you
have this very unique perspective of
this one year one year planning and you
you uh you just have an interesting
perspective and life style to me so what
is your personal on game that was not
that into I live in the East Village in
a tiny apartment like to eat pizza and
game when do you walk away you walk away
when you're not doing interesting work
when it's not fun anymore when you're
not enjoying when the pain of going to
work become so much that it's not worth
and you everyone's been there and that's
when you're like okay you wrapped up as
long as you can keep going and you like
hanging out with your friends and you're
doing cool things keep keep doing and
this is the longest job ever rap I never
thought we would be here this is my
sixth year working on this it's mostly
because the community that we have is so
good that I actually there is no other
place I can legitimately say this that I
would rather go work because I go to
work with my friends every day and the
the work changes everyday but that's
much more interesting as soon as all my
friends left I would be like okay we
probably have to figure out something
else well answer that most recent
question in a second but before we do
how you you're you're you're painting a
very nice foot picture of loving to go
to work how many times have you felt
this is horrible I'm out of here
I quit like every day but I mean that's
that's the day that that means you care
like if you just have our apathetic that
means you don't care at all like it's
better to care and be like okay but I'll
get there tomorrow I think the
difference is for me I've been doing
this for 25 years and so like I'll
always keep doing this is like this is
like my thing you know like I I will do
another one after this and keep doing it
and doing it and if I can work with my
friends so for me this is all about
getting VCS to pay for my life so that I
don't have to get a real job and I don't
have to work at Facebook or Google
because who wants to work in a carpeted
office place that's so weird because
carpet in New York is disgusting
every feet outside so for me it's really
about maintaining like just being
creative as doing as much as I can do
and if if I can get my friends to do it
I'll keep doing this forever if you can
keep going on and it's fun why not like
a little where else am I gonna work
probably I mean I'm really bad at making
coffee too so probably nowhere let's
address this question down here Alex
about giffy ads right now I don't see a
lot of advertisement or ads on Kippy but
what happens if you take it to the limit
and try to and try to it's right here
this last time let's say you take it to
the limit and you try to monetize as
much as possible what's that going to
look like that and how you think it how
you think that's gonna impact users so
the secret which most of you I think
people don't understand is you have
already been all sending branded content
90% of all the content our site is
branded we just don't haven't charged
for it so you've already sent an ad we
just never got paid for it and so you
people are like oh these ads are going
to be disruptive guess what they're
already all at like 90% of them are as
we just haven't put a pay gateway on to
wait what does that mean what why do you
why are you saying their ads already
because it's all branded content so most
of our content comes from trailers from
movies they come from McDonald's from
like Pepsi from all these places they're
all these brands are putting up content
every day like the WWE does a really
good job of putting up you know these
promos for like things going on scenes
this is all advertising for them
we just haven't charged them yet I see
we have for a few of them and we will
for all of them not except for the ones
we like because they're awesome because
what's the difference between an ad and
good content you know there is no
difference in this world
let's do maybe two or three more
questions let's say answer this one
about mistake so you've grown to over a
hundred people now 150 million dollars
in funding what are some of the biggest
mistakes that you've made and what have
you learned along the way
I know there's a ton huh just the top
two like every mistake you ever think
you're gonna make we've probably made
like like everywhere everywhere yeah
what did they say I think I saw this in
a fortune cookie
the master is one that makes 10,000
mistakes like the the thing is if you're
not making mistakes that means you're
not trying hard enough and you're not
actually progressing so I would say
biggest mistakes have been making a gift
search engine but that ended up being
turning out pretty well I don't know I'm
too big of a question like everything
okay wearing today was a mistake and why
why don't you or why do you dislike
Google and Facebook so much and you
dislike them so much so they came and
offered a massive amount of money would
you sell them matters how much money
like it it always matters on how much
money but know the difference between
Google and say those it's fine I've
worked at a large big companies but for
anyone young that's trying to do
interesting things you know they just
have it is it is a different it is like
it may be the way to put this if you're
like an indie rock band and you just
want to make good music there are these
huge huge bands that kind of just take
all the market share and like our
monopolies and and we like working with
them but I mean like I actually love
Facebook and Google like we have a lot
of friends there we work with all their
product teams but we are just a
different type of business and we're
competing like we're competitive right
and so I would say I don't really have a
beef with the companies I Maura have if
you're young and you're interesting I
think you should try to do something
else first and then go retire there when
you're old and boring I'm gonna ask just
one more question
so go ahead and pull up the app and and
vote on anything you want and I'll try
to wait a second until we see some of
the some of the top ones but before I
get to that last one you can see all the
amass ghosts you see a massive amount of
gifts what's the favorite mostly what's
your favorite one that you've seen
that changes every like five minutes we
probably like yes people can upload
gifts on giffy they can upload we get
millions of uploads well here to this
what's the most popular one on the
platform it literally changes every 10
minutes
it changes on what what's going on
popular what's going on in the world
right now like a few weeks ago as ariana
grande now it's cardi B now it'll be
anything that's really going on pop
culture it's kind of saying like what's
the most popular thing in your head
right now like I don't know I won't
forgot it
don't you have all-time stats yeah but
but but popular for today or for all
time all the time well all time is tough
because all time is like you get the
history of momentum if you go to youtube
you know the all-time best videos are
like it's not like it was like evolution
of the dance for like years sure but
there's a most popular one what's it for
on your platform in terms of all-time
most popular well for 2018 it was a car
it was cardi B on Jimmy Fallon saying
ocher you seen that and that and that's
that was like the most popular of all
time or of 2018 of all time it's you
know probably some random cat gift
that's been around for 20 years cat
playing piano that's a good one okay
last question when let's do the I don't
think you could see here we'll do this
one it's the most it's the most up voted
the future of the business of the
company what's gonna happen in the next
one
I know you don't like planning so five
years I don't know probably have
self-driving cars get gift fee like gift
e pizza I don't who knows what's gonna
happen in five years but the next thing
that we're doing is we you know we went
gifts we went stickers and really now
that we're messaging we're really about
bringing content and new formats to
messaging so we launched a video
platform three weeks ago at the Metro
graph we'd had a
premiere of a very short short 18 second
or less video Film Festival
casing nice dad and some of our friends
from a moment the met were judges so in
q1 we're gonna launch an entire short
form video plot product which is
basically the number one reason way
people are gonna watch content and
messaging so that will be something that
you should watch for it's coming out
very soon the future really is if we are
search for messaging we are going to
take a large percentage and our goal is
to be 50 percent of Google search we're
gonna be and then a hundred percent of
Google search and then we our goal is to
take out Google first from search so
that we can be the old company that you
don't really want to work at but that's
okay cuz we will all be old and boring
and so we will love our jobs and then
we're gonna go after Comcast and take
out all the media because no one watches
long-form TV unless it's on Netflix
anymore so we think content can be much
much shorter all the great shows like
The Today Show Good Morning America I
don't know anyone that's young that
watches those but there should be
versions of it
HQ is doing a good job of making game
shows more fun but what about all of
daytime TV that supposedly millions of
people in Middle America watch but no
one but no one here watches if you're
here otherwise you'd be at home watching
TV but I think the future really is
going to be a combination of messaging
and communication networks where media
comes into that and it's going to be a
big mix of a crazy world where new
content is going to be invented new
formats are going to be invented and the
ways that people we watch it are going
to be totally new and you can kind of
see the trend this is why 18 T and Time
Warner Verizon all these communication
companies are merging with entertainment
companies because the future really is
when entertainment messaging
communications search are all one
platform so that's the long-term vision
we we want to take out basically all of
the people in communication and
entertainment put it into one platform
that's very similar to look with an MTV
brand
and make advertising not be horrible
because advertising on the internet
sucks so bad that it's really really
painful and we have the one advertising
format that actually doesn't suck that
people send every day millions million
hundreds of millions of time today
billions probably billions let's
actually wrap up with the quick answer
to this last one currently what's
stressing you out the most throughout
your day stressing like what yeah what
stresses you out
oh man everything is seamlessly like
things seem like they're going great the
company does I mean you know you've got
to keep the company everyone employed so
my number one duty is to make sure
everyone in the company is happy and
they were currently employed and that we
can get to keep doing that so that's a
stress like the whole political climate
peace in the Middle East I don't know I
didn't eat anything all day so I'm kind
of like a little dizzy
I drank like three cups of coffee before
I got here so pretty much everything in
the world is probably stressing me out
right now and then I'll go back to work
and my friends will just chill me out
and that's kind of work is more like the
less the least stressful place of the
world and then this whole situation
going on here I think you guys probably
stressed at me out a little bit too so
maybe that's it well if only we could
all be so light-hearted as you but I
just wouldn't hearted I'm totally
serious yeah that's my takeaway well
look I appreciate you coming man I'm a
huge fan of gippy maybe you'll be
hanging out for a few more minutes
before you head out but thank you for
coming I know people still might have
some questions afterwards will they be
able to cut you over here sure I think
so I'll be over there with my entourage
turtle there they are right over here
well look thanks for coming man we
really appreciate it we've learned a lot
and I and I appreciate you taking time